[Musik]
hallo herr tobias elis welt ab heute ein
leckeres rezept für euch ich hatte lust
auch blaubeeren und kommt nicht so recht
entscheiden mache ich einen blauwal also
blueberry pj oder mache ich eine
blaupause
also habe ich mir gedacht warum nicht
einfach beides kombinieren und jetzt
habe ich hier eine blaue wer zeit hat
global report und war eine tat wie immer
nun richtig schönen möbel lutz und die
kepler hat aber so eine richtig tolle
verfasst flüssige füllung und der sicht
des spiels kühlung und jetzt beide sind
verbunden habe jetzt hier außen einen
schoko espresso website
das ganze wird auf den teil also fast
optimal
jedenfalls ist der kuchen musik slacker
vor allem sicher genau meinem geschmack
mit espresso kakao schokolade und
blaubeeren und mit einem klecks sahne
etwas wirklich eine super form parks
rezept ich jetzt erst einmal wie ich bin
website machen dann wird auch die
füllung denkst du bereitet und ihr vorne
stehen mit blut hatte für den missbrauch
von circa 160 gramm kalte butter etwas
sonne extrakt und eine prise salz 200
gramm mehl und 40 com kakaopulver und
einen espresso sinn habe ich bereits
abkühlen lassen und für die füllung
brauche ich 600 von blaubeeren entweder
frische oder tiefgekühlte 60 gramm herum
schokolade oder twitter schokolade etwa
100 gramm zucker vier teelöffel stärke
und eine unbehandelte limette
ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal mit der
möglichkeit an deswegen gebe ich jetzt
zucker und butter die informations und
wir könnten zeit auch mit dem hinten
verkneten
sollte aber bei mürbeteig immer darauf
achten dass der teig schön kalt bleibt
damit eben erfährt jetzt ein extrakt
und dann wird werden die zutaten
miteinander verbunden
und falls jetzt eine küchenmaschine habt
könnt ihr auch einen mix zum beispiel
nehmen oder nehmen sondern zeigte hacker
und zwar ist er stumpf ihr könnt auch
zum beispiel nehmen müsse aber aufpassen
dass ich nicht schneidet tom tykwer geht
auch wunderbar da kann man den zeit
wirklich wunderbar vermischen
jetzt gehe ich mit kakaopulver das wohl
und dann hört so viel espresso das eben
ein schöner tag entsteht eben auch nicht
zu weit
[Musik]
jüngster zeit heraus und formen kurzen
bei einer kugel zusammen
und dann muss er mindestens eine halbe
stunde gekühlt werden
[Musik]
weiter teilt kann ich schon mal die
füllung zu bereiten sie muss vor
gedruckt werden damit auch anschließend
princess wird das baby jetzt die
blaubeeren in einem topf und ich habe
die tiefgekühlte blaubeeren weil einfach
momentan keine blösse
aber falls ihr gerade in der blockarbeit
könnt ihr natürlich auf frische glauben
verwenden
sein herz schon mal an gibt zucker dazu
da noch nicht komplett alles ich mache
ich eher dass die füllung säuerlich und
das heißt louis ist deswegen schmecke
ich das jetzt gleich erst einmal ab ein
bisschen limettenschale kommt mit rein
die passt wunderbar
und wer möchte kann noch mit einer prise
zimt verfeinert auch wunderbar das los
und sobald das ganze kosmos schon jetzt
schon auch noch stärker dafür dass das
ganze jetzt einfach mal ein kochen
wer möchte kann jetzt hier auch ein
bisschen limettensaft geben ich mache
ich es auch eben weil steuerlichen gerne
mag
[Musik]
doch jetzt bei mir bei mittlerer stufe
etwa 45 minuten lang ein kochen schalt
dein herz und die seele nicht wundervoll
auf der hut sein und vor allem riechen
susanne kant jetzt kommt hier die herren
schokolade mit rein heißt habe ich die
schokolade auch mit drin
und sobald die schokolade eingerührt ist
kann ich hier den deckel zumachen und
kann einfach die füllung ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen bis der teig eben auch
so weiter jetzt geht's weiter jetzt der
teig gut durchgeführt und jetzt nehme
ich ein bisschen mehr arbeitsfläche und
wer dann immer noch kurz durchkneten
[Musik]
gut
mit rollt ihn auf etwa 30 bis 32 cm
größe auf um dann später hat diese tat
vom mitgeboten aufzuzeigen
geht man durchmesser von 25 zentimetern
und ich brauche hier auf beiden seiten
noch den rand mit bättig die tat vom mit
wachstums- und lege jetzt den tag über
den ort kloster und breiten dann hätte
aber auch und wird ihn eben schön rein
[Musik]
und die überreste nehmen einfach mit
seinem tortenring messer weg
normalerweise mag ich dann den teig
immer ein bisschen vor ort damit die tat
einfach schön möbel wird jetzt mit viel
topspin peinlich machen das heißt jetzt
nicht vor sondern gebe zu viel gleich
die füllung mit rein
es gibt auch schon abgekühlt
[Musik]
und auch wenn ty kristens freue mich
jetzt ganz typisch noch einen schönen
satz gesagt dass das wieder schön aus
kennst du und schweizern streifen
[Musik]
und könnt ihr hier ernst nach belieben
entweder ein gitter zu überlegen
oder so wie ich jetzt einfach einen
knopf an den rand
[Musik]
hobby schon mal richtig gut aus mit über
deckungsgrad noch hier diese kleinen
lippe mit ein paar kleinen selbst
geformten blaubeeren und wir werden
einfach mit ein bisschen wasser
festgeklebt
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die hübsche partei in den
backofen und fahrten zum auf 170 grad
ober unterhitze vorgeheizt und da muss
für etwa 40 bis 45 minuten backen
[Musik]
die charts gebacken und abwickelt und
jetzt kann ich die erste form
herauslösen ich nehme es ein kleines
schönes draus
ganz vorsichtig lösen es geht einfach
mit zu einer palette macht unter das
ganze und standen kann die täter anhand
von vier auf eine tortenplatte der murat
war das schon ganz gespannt darauf was
ausprobieren darf ich schreibe trägt
einiges leicht zu erklären ist ein teil
schön aber einfach wird schon claude
wieder ganz genau weil erneut genau die
mitte weil man schon verschneiden wissen
hast du den ersten die erste zeit hat
oder traf vor allem je nachdem was du
noch und warum weiter weil ich einfach
diese tat nicht gebacken haben ohne
übliche tag bereichert mit den mittag
vorgebacken sondern ich habe gleich mit
dem teig und erfüllen gleichzeitig wenn
ich mich mal probieren und aus dem
restlichen teig noch ein bisschen zeit
gehabt habe ich hier so kwp kleine
espressobohnen gemacht von kohl durch
liebsten im sommer mache ich mal als
rezept macht könnt ihr noch zu feiern
und um gibt es kleine etwas pixel also
dass sich die ganze spannung beim
schmecken die füllung ein bisschen
cremig durch die schokolade
und der schnitt nicht zu süß da ist auch
unser herr wegen werden
schokolade wer schokolade ein bisschen
barrick und ob ich hier noch ein express
verlässt die schon geschmack nicht zu
vergessen die sahne dazu schlagen ich
brauche wahrscheinlich neben die absolut
nicht absolut nicht sie sahen dem stand
ein bisschen zu trocken ist oder ein
bisschen trockener strecke richtig voll
wird ich glaub ich stürze mich auch
gleich darauf ob ein stück auf ein stück
nicht auf dem ganzen kreis und fast
jedes rezept nachlesen wollte nachmachen
wollen jedes meinen blog aus paris - bob
de ich freue mich wenn ihr das wird nach
macht und wenn ihr dann ein foto auf
dienste komplett und und verlinkt das
schaut immer mal wieder rein und leiter
wintersport und deswegen zeit hart weil
aber der mürbeteig von bin von der tat
also eigentlich die geniale mischung aus
nach unten
insofern höhle der löwen perfekt
bis zum nächsten mal entließ das extra
apfel schön
an
[Musik]
borken